ça sent la façon un peu en dépôt quand
même ça sent un petit peu en règle que
voilà c'est ça c'était donc ils écoutent
fait c'étaient des choses serait qu'il
ait un tapis
[Applaudissements]
trop différent trop grand anormaux en
large
notre histoire a trop longtemps été
occulté par celle du livre à grand
tirage
il est temps d'écrire une nouvelle page
de cette histoire et de faire valoir nos
droits artistiques et littéraires
aujourd'hui la majorité d'entre nous
sommes édité au format poche couverture
souple blanche la plupart du temps les
impératifs de vente veulent faire de
nous des livres bien pensants calibré
pour les têtes de gondole bannissant la
couleur le multiculturalisme
typographique ou encore la diversité des
papiers nous pensons que la diversité
est l'existence d'autres formats sont
nécessaires à la société du livre nous
ferons de libération du livre demandons
un traitement égalitaire et lançons cet
appel de solidarité visant à la
reconnaissance de notre identité propre
dont la diversité des genres des formes
et des contenus fait la richesse
ensemble avec la médiathèque de valence
qui soutient notre combat luttons contre
ces clichés littéraire et
l'antisémitisme
il ya plusieurs réactions possibles en
fait généralement ça intéresse toujours
va vraiment ça suscite la curiosité
parce qu'effectivement le grand public
de manière générale à voile avec plutôt
dans le livre traditionnel et que là
c'est vrai qu'on a tout de suite même
s'il ya toujours la notion de textes
d'image de quelque chose qui est un
petit peu quand même entier ou qui se
rapporte à la littérature
il ya toujours un lien au livre voilà
mais ça peut exprimer avec des matières
différentes et des livres en bois
délivrant pierre délivrant vers des
livres avec émoi la couverture en métal
et puis après il ya même une façon de
travailler livre qui peut être en
accordéon qui peut être sur une base de
caillet qui peut être un des pliages
voilà donc c'est vrai qu'on est face à
une oeuvre qui sort un petit peu de
l'ordinaire
nous vivons une époque frileuse et
conformiste l'âge d'or des publications
libre est derrière nous mais ce n'est
pas une fatalité
certains d'entre nous résistons contre
le recours systémique à la table des
matières l'homogénéisation des marges et
le devoir de quatrième de couverture
nous appelons à l' usage de toutes les
formes et aspects du livre possible
métal bois carton paquets de cigarettes
on a donc la réutilisation d'une boîte
de cigarettes
mais voilà il ya déjà quelque chose
c'est un bateau et quand on ouvre en
fait c'est une c'est la poésie les
conquérants de josé maria de heredia
donc c'est vrai que tout fait sens et en
fait il a réalisé le poème se trouve ici
et ensuite on a les illustrations qui a
fait de ce voile à de sa vision de la
peau de cette foule et zila nous
maintenons aussi l'idée du droit de nous
affranchir du texte refusons l'exclusion
et la discrimination de ceux et celles
qui se battent pour la mise en page
libre le choix du sens de lecture la
récupération de matériaux accueillons
les autres arts et offrons leur droit de
séjour gravures peintures collages et
dessins
cette diversité est notre force quoi
qu'en disent les partisans de
l'académisme puritains qui voudraient
nous passer au karcher blanchir notre
couverture
ce manifeste est inspiré par de grands
noms
mathis ballard et tyson jaune au clair
qui ont servi et défendu notre cause
livres du monde entier rejoignez notre
mouvement
ouvrons dialogue et laissons libre cours
à notre imagination en acceptant toutes
les formes de familles de livres genre
et non genres et toutes les formes de
lecture et d'écriture au long de toutes
et tous nous vous remercions
voilà sept exemplaires en parler
peut-être
mais du coup chaque exemplaire et aux
geeks
voilà donc là c'est que c'est
effectivement un registre de présence
d'une école maternelle qui a été
récupérée dans un grenier et du coup il
a loupé ce travail comédie grâce à jour
la machine à laver des idées
[Musique]